ae
e vou contar com uma pergunta e eu vou
limpando para levantarem andaluz que não
consiga ninguém e eu clico já sem o
braço no ar quem é que aqui é pai ou mãe
não discrimina ninguém
temos que aliar teoria da sala é como
pai e mãe podem baixar nos outra vez que
é mais fácil projetar uma em cada três
crianças em portugal é assim tem chefe
peso e muitas delas são obesas
isto é o que vão ser os pais trazem para
hidratar os vossos filhos em casa
eu estou falando aqui uma criança em
portugal com o som por semana cinco
refrigerante
estamos a falar de 260 latas 86 litros
dos quais aproximadamente itália é
açúcar e uma bíblia em vez de hidratar
desidrata ao invés de ver iremos
consumir a volta uma criança deverá
consumir a volta de 105 litros de água
por ano
eu pessoalmente vou fazer as contas
assim
rapidamente estamos a falar de 1.080
litros de água por ano que o consumo
os números são é absolutamente amandí
chute antes
estamos a falar de uma criança consome
conforme falar em 5 refrigerante por
semana
mais de 90% das crianças consomem
fastfood 2% e 10 bem água e alimentos
trinta e oito e meio por cento das
crianças têm chefe peso das quais 15%
aproximadamente são obesas
isto é uma epidemia dessa maneira agir
numa faixa etária do gênero ou seis anos
poderemos ir até aos dez mas geram chefe
é quando está provado científicamente
que é quando as crianças desenvolvem o
seu caráter sua forma de estar na vida o
que gostam e que não gostam tanto se nós
investirmos nesta área
as crianças vão passar para as próximas
gerações e aos próprios vão crescer
influênciando quem está assim em seu
grande
e as da realidade em portugal
nós vemos as cantinas deparamo nos com
pratos mal confeccionados com produtos e
matéria-prima maioritariamente com os
lados e depois nos deparamos com as
máquinas que vendem 11 barsil a mãe
desse processo do do tempo fui informado
que é uma diretriz do ministério da
educação e talvez do ministério da saúde
onde as marcas vendem são proibidas mas
elas continuam a existir e além de
continuar a existir os vários vendem
tudo isto
toda a gente culpa as empresas de
catering
mas eu acho que é muito injusto culpar
as empresas que têm exclusivamente
porque com 76 cêntimos por refeição para
dar de comer uma criança onde inclui um
empregado coordenada
comigo é não se admirem se encontrar em
sopas foi deixou o guns de dados de
picante mas como eu sou uma pessoa
positiva e eu acredito que a solução
para tudo
nós vamos à procura e encontrarmos um
caso único no mundo e que me dá um
grande alento no uruguai
o presidente uruguaio foi muito
trabalhoso e protegeu as suas crianças
olhou para as suas crianças e diz ela
está nem comer bem todos os dias porque
a maioria dos nossos filhos fazem a
maioria dos nossos das suas refeições
nas escolas nós temos que olhar
obviamente para escolas e pensar que
está a solução e uma boa alimentação e
já cheguei a firmar e já cheguei a fazer
uma grande entrevista onde diz
os portugueses não sabem com os números
provam-no eu não preciso de me defender
e isso não vai foi foram apresentados
este vários que vocês podem vender fruta
fresca
os golos os tudo que ela vende total
desmatada tem inclusive uma lista dos
gomes primitivo e não permitidas
e eu acredito que se o governo
ministério da educação ministério da
saúde se envolverem a série a vão
resolver problemas muito mais graves que
hoje em dia se fala que são os problemas
de saúde
11 da leva o movimento é uma série de
doenças que não se refletem enquanto
criança mas vamos refletir muito mais
tarde enquanto adultos
portanto o problema da saúde que hoje em
dia é o nosso governo tem pode ser
solucionado se apostarem nas crianças de
escreverem boa comida e boa
matéria-prima
nascimento foi lançada a câmara
municipal de lisboa convidou me para eu
entrar virá em conjunto num
projecto-piloto nós vamos agir numa
escola que vai ter 300 alunos no próximo
ano letivo tanto durante este ano nós
vamos desenvolver uma série de ações que
para mim são fundamentais na formação do
pessoal workshops em escolas e quando
fala que o workshop em escolas e eu falo
é no envolvimento de toda a comunidade
porque não pode ser feita apenas na
escola senão vários pais junto dos
alunos nos levar para um é cozinha de
aulas e nessa cozinha de aulas que pode
pertencer a um plano curricular
vamos ter resultados criarem idênticos
ao da reciclagem na reciclagem
ela foi levada para as escolas nas
escolas ensinavam as crianças a reciclar
elas levarão esse conhecimento para casa
influenciaram os pais hoje em dia em
casa criaram a pulsão poucas as casas em
portugal há gente que não se recicla
escalar na europa somos um país per
capita que mais reciclam esse é um
motivo de orgulho e eu acredito que isto
pontos tornar viral
o livro com hábitos de alimentação
saudável obviamente que é fundamental
mas literatura às nossas crianças e os
pais com a ajuda do zero desperdício
também vamos deixar de ter desperdício
alimentar das escolas e obviamente
implementar a hábitos saudáveis nas
cantinas reduzindo o número de de vezes
que se come carne reduzindo a quantidade
de sal que é utilizada nas refeições e
obviamente colocando frutas legumes que
vão obviamente melhorar a qualidade da
alimentação dos nossos filhos produtos
frescos
com isso a parceria com um com
produtores locais de amplos boa que
muitas vezes têm dificuldades no
escoamento dos seus produtos porque as
grandes superfícies consomem tudo
esta parceria vai ser fundamental para
que a matéria prima de boa qualidade
chegue à mesa dos nossos filhos
eu vou contar uma história muito
resumida em 2004 infelizmente o meu
pagam e numa doença muito fulminante
teve um cancro no pâncreas
mas antes eu já tinha deve directx já
tinha triglicérides já tem uma série de
doenças devido à sua má alimentação
falta de desporto e claro um mau estilo
de vida
vejo isso com tristeza e e e não
aprender nada com a morte do meu pai na
morte do meu pai eu aprendi uma grande
coisa que foi eu não vou continuar a ser
assim
na altura trabalhava em londres numa
escola de estrela michelin em uma escola
na moça diz ter uma missão é e e mudar e
realmente a minha alimentação porque eu
não poderia mais continuar a pactuar com
o restaurante onde só cozinho fagá
manteiga gorduras saturadas e açúcares
que vão fazer mal
iniciei este processo obviamente com os
meus filhos primeiro com 11 com dois até
que eu acredito que antes vão ser o
melhor exemplo e que vão influenciar o
máximo de pessoas em voz em seu rancho
mas há um movimento que o meu objetivo
não chega e não quero ficar por aqui eu
acredito que vamos chegar a todos os
filhos de portugal
juntos vamos conseguir
obrigado